Unsere Vorfahren haben sich aufgegessen!
Und Forschungsteams weltweit rätseln schon
seit langer Zeit, ob dies am Nahrungsmangel
lag oder aber ob kulturelle und soziale Gründe
eine Rolle spielten.
Experten aus Spanien haben jetzt endlich eine
Antwort auf diese Frage parat.
Und ihre Erkenntnisse sind wirklich mehr als
gruselig.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Das spanische Forschungsteam hatte Fossilien
aus der Gran Dolina-Höhle nördlich der Stadt
Burgos genauer analysiert.
Diese stammen vom “Homo antecessor”, der
vor rund 900.000 Jahren lebte.
Die Bezeichnung bedeutet so viel wie “Vorläufer
des anatomisch modernen Menschen”.
Fest steht jedenfalls, dass Vertreter des
Homo Antecessors den gesamten Körper ihrer
toten Mitmenschen verzehrt haben.
Das spanische Forschungsteam entdeckte jetzt
nämlich eindeutige Anzeichen für die kannibalistische
Praxis.
Dazu Jesus Rodriguez, einer der beteiligten
Forscher: “Die menschlichen Körper wurden
gehäutet, ausgeweidet und entbeint.
Die Langknochen wurden zerbrochen, um an das
Knochenmark zu gelangen.
Zudem sind auf mehreren menschlichen und tierischen
Überresten Bissspuren dokumentiert.“
Die Experten gehen aufgrund der Muster der
Schäden davon aus, dass unsere Vorfahren
nicht nur die Rippenknochen ihrer Artgenossen
angekaut und angelutscht haben, sondern den
toten Körper mitsamt dem Gehirn und den Organen
gegessen haben.
Ein echt gruseliges Mahl!
Und das gehörte wohl vor knapp einer Million
Jahren zum Alltag dieser Frühmenschen!
Doch warum genau?
Fest steht bislang nur, dass der Kannibalismus
zur Menschheitsgeschichte gehört und eine
alte weit verbreitete Praxis ist.
Manche Fachleute gehen davon aus, dass dies
an sozialen und kulturellen Gründen lag.
Oder aßen sie sich ganz einfach gegenseitig
auf, um ihren Kalorienbedarf zu decken?!
Dagegen aber spricht, dass diese Frühmenschen
keinesfalls an Nahrungsmangel litten.
Das verraten Tierknochen, die in derselben
Fundschicht zahlreich vorhanden sind.
Deswegen gehen die spanischen Fachleute nicht
davon aus, dass unsere Vorfahren aufgrund
Hunger zu Menschenfressern wurden.
Ihrer Berechnung zufolge hätten wohl 20 Gruppenangehörige
drei Monate lang allein durch die Tiere mit
einer ausreichenden Essensmenge versorgt werden
können.
Zudem zeigt das Verhältnis der aufgespürten
Menschenknochen zu Tierknochen, dass die Frühmenschen
absichtlich anderen Frühmenschen als ihr
Essen auswählten.
Und zwar aus einem Grund: Die jungen menschlichen
Opfer waren die lohnendste Beute.
Viel leichter zu erbeuten als Hirsche oder
Nashörner.
Zu diesem gruseligen Ergebnis kam das spanische
Forschungsteam durch die Anwendung eines klassischen
Beutewahl-Modells auf die Knochenfunde von
Gran Dolina.
Demnach wählen Tiere oder Menschen eben die
Beute, die zum einen die meiste Energie liefert
und zum anderen mit dem kleinsten Aufwand
zu erbeuten ist.
Homo antecessor war also Kannibale, weil sich
das am meisten lohnte.
Geklärt ist damit aber noch nicht, wie die
Opfer zu Tode kamen.
Wurden sie bei Konflikten getötet und dann
als Nahrung konsumiert - ähnlich wie bei
Schimpansen?
Oder wurden die Opfer einfach durch einen
frühen natürlichen Tod zur Mahlzeit?!
Dazu heißt es in der Studie: „Die einfachste
Erklärung könnte sein, dass diese Opfer
zur gleichen Gruppe wie die Kannibalen gehörten
und eines natürlichen Todes starben“.
Ethnographische Daten sprechen für diese
Erklärung, denn demnach sterben bei Jäger-
und Sammler-Völkern bis zu 65 Prozent der
Stammesangehörigen, bevor sie überhaupt
das Erwachsenen-Alter erreichen.
Höchstwahrscheinlich machte Homo antecessor
also das Beste aus dem frühen Tod seiner
Artgenossen und nutzte diese als zusätzliche
Nahrung.
Ist "Planet der Affen" realistisch?
Und jetzt kommen die drei As: anklicken anscheun
und astro comics TV abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!